la pregunta más urgente y persistente de
la vida es
qué estás haciendo todos los demás
la primera ocasión que escuche esta
frase y después de la biografía me
embarco definitivamente la verdad y para
ser honesto jamás pensé que me compañía
que me acompañaría toda la vida
yo soy ingeniero y curiosamente los
últimos años de mi vida de ingeniero he
pasado a creativo tuve la fortuna de
formar parte del primer equipo que
diseñó una recicladora en base a energía
geotérmica y todo esto en concreto es
musical y si entendí entendí que de nada
se envía está el innovando tecnología de
carácter mundial están innovando
procesos si éstos no se comunicaban de
manera eficiente preparando una sorpresa
como ingeniero entender que los
creativos utilizaban cosas medio
extrañas para comunicar y que lo
complejo de una palabra se podía
transmitir de una manera muy rápida
entonces lo que empecé a hacer
lo que empecé a hacer es me enamoré de
parte de la parte de comunicación de la
parte de marketing
por más de 25 años he estado comunicando
marcas y empresas y organizaciones
civiles
la parte interesante es que la frase de
nuevo no marcó y empecé a construir
vehículos de recaudación para organismos
civiles
hace 10 años la frase del nuevo regreso
conmigo y tuve que despertarme la
palabra de éxito una situación personal
un giro inesperado de vida hizo que todo
se colapsara que mi realidad cambiará de
manera dramática y de repente pues ya no
sabía qué hacer ya no sabía qué hacer y
tenía que comunicarme con mis clientes
más importantes con la parte más
importante de mi vida que eran mis
hijos'
topcom explicarles a los niños un
proceso de divorcio un fracaso personal
de pareja y la verdad estaba muy
inquieto no sabía cómo solucionar esta
parte y lo único que atiné fueron tres
abuelos por supuesto los niños y los
niños que interactúan entre sí donde los
abuelos con la experiencia y la salud
iría les quitaban a los niños que pues
están en problemas de adultos no pasaba
nada no había ningún problema pero pues
bueno renuncias que sigan siendo niños
como como cómo manejar tuve que
reinventar
la palabra éxito de funcionario pero
tuve que entender el avance más baja de
la situación que había otras formas de
volver a empezar y con mucho miedo
intenté e intente hasta que empezamos de
alguna manera a entender que la
comunicación con los líneas me permitía
volver a estudiar volver a imaginar y
empezar en lo que era la ciudad y fue
por primera ocasión en más de 20 años
que tienen una voltereta a entender lo
que pasaba en la ciudad y les cuenta que
en el mundo había una serie de iconos
una serie de elementos distintivos
descripción tengo que decir que la foto
es en china para que entiendan que en a
morelia es distintiva
tampoco tengo que decir que esto es país
ni tengo que decir que en egipto habitan
o existen animales identitarios y iconos
online marx todo esto me llevó a
preguntarme qué pasará con islas
lo primero que vi en mi ciudad es nada
más pero que pasaba a poner el
diferenciador de mi ciudad quiera o no
si la tijuana tiene un distintivo muy
muy muy particular empezamos a
investigar empezamos a entender que
podíamos construir puentes con el pasado
para comunicar empezamos a entender que
la palabra experiencia personalmente
pareciera que todo mi pasado estaba
listo para que en este momento de mi
vida circunstancial crítico poder
comunicarlo en una manera más eficiente
hacia mis hijos que era la parte que más
memoria
si eres a contarle las tradiciones de la
ciudad pero pues como una imagen
hay mucho que decir
en 15 años estuve manejando
organizaciones civiles con un techo
comercial que se llama unidos por lo que
que haya cuentas que había que darle
personalidad jurídica y forme la hace
pero para que si lo que yo estaba
tratando de transmitir era como a través
de las tradiciones de los hitos de los
de las leyendas poder comunicar a los
jóvenes y qué mejor manera de
transformarnos ciudad que así y nació
con relatos o relatos por supuesto son
tres abuelos todos bueno cebras que le
encuentran a sus nietos todos los gustos
e impuestos las historias de la ciudad
porque resulta que están tijuana no hay
pirámides dos edificios coloniales no
hay un pancho villa que nos pone en un
contexto nacional
pero tenemos un duro con rayas y este
foro con rayas ha sido el testigo mundo
de la evolución de nuestra ciudad pese a
quien le pese ha estado con nosotros por
más tiempo que muchas de las tradiciones
puedo decir que es la tradición más
longeva que existe en la ciudad
investigar y documentamos que la
revisión de más de 100 años en una 130
que sucedió pues nos dimos cuenta que
aludí no les funcionaba y entonces
borrel a todos el proyecto que era para
mis hijos resultó ser una ramita muy
poderosa para comunicarle a los niños y
resulta que los vídeos no nos podían
comunicar elementos importantísimos de
cómo nacen las historias y de repente
hicimos una escultura de muro gigantesca
para experimentar qué sucedía porque
todo esto ha sido un piloto y un burro
una escultura con la palabra de juanín
welcome genera orgullo genera identidad
gente al sentido de pertenencia por
nacional
de hecho las las esculturas cuentan
historias ya tenemos un chef muy
orgulloso que se remangó la raya que
está preparando
es decir teníamos que sintetizar para
poder comunicarnos con los niños caídos
a cuenta que podíamos hacer un gran
mural y esconder el de 200 historias de
subida de 12 metros
esto es impactante cuando lo ven a gente
y se acerca y ese será el propósito como
provocar orgullo arraigo identidad
sentido de pertenencia estar orgulloso
de lo que estoy haciendo
el proceso está interesante
es el más fotogénico
y por supuesto ha sido diferenciada de
una ciudad yo sé que no alcanzan a ver
al burro pero hay un burro en cada foto
uno que es negro y uno que es blanco y
no se alcanza a ver precisamente porque
en aquel entonces cuando la fotografía
ente sabrá si pudo se unirían esto es
así porque nada más buscaban a los
burros de color gris
esta foto está muy interesante el
distintivo de mi ciudad es que el que
viene no vino si no tratamos la foto con
el gorro si alguien reconoce la imagen
les comparto
él se llama scout fisio y ella se llama
regla crahan es importante porque
tijuana era la meca del universo en los
años 30
eres kb nivel de arremangarse
estos dos se llaman rage y brand
industria en el 53 se tomaron las fotos
de juana porque tenían que venir y
realmente ven un loco que quiere salvar
la tradición de un burro y regresan y
juande se toman las fotos 60 años
después
él se llama chequea trans en la
comunidad judía es un éver porque en la
época más triste del holocausto
con sus amigos china nos han escuchado
de judíos de méxico y él es el precursor
de la zona rosa en el delfinario sabe si
aquí tenemos al incinerado en todas las
películas tenemos otros prinstein y
espuma seducida de imágenes la realidad
es que esta tradición que tiene más de
100 años y de tener más de 30 carretas
en la avenida revolución es sesenta
burros pues perdieron la guerra están en
una crisis terrible hay una brecha
generacional y tecnológica abismal y
decidimos que tenemos que oxigenar la
que tenemos que solucionar de alguna
manera que eso lo que hicimos lo que
hicimos fue primero entender que atrás
de la tradición hay personas personas
que toda su vida han trabajado aquí y
desafortunadamente si se los comió el
tiempo ya todas las personas de la
tercera edad esta tradición está
dictaminado oficialmente en vías de
extinción
quisimos diseñamos un servicio que le
llamamos war to go donde literalmente
llevamos muchos homicidios porque ya los
clientes toman a la revolución como lo
hacemos pues lo hacemos con la aburrida
era
y lo hacemos con una multi moral que
cuenta las historias de mi ciudad y esto
fue mágico la gente se acerca a la gente
se toma la foto y estamos aquí en el
burro bus tomándose la foto con el burro
y las autoridades automáticamente no
pasado nada con ellos problema está pero
afortunadamente ya les pudimos
proporcionar seguro popular a estas
personas que tienen toda la vida
representando a la ciudad empezamos a
dignificar el oficio dignificar la
profesión y logramos celebrar en palacio
municipal y llevarlos a un estatus de
microempresarios
finalmente estábamos logrando algo nos
llevan el patrimonio cultural inmaterial
del estado de baja california para estar
el imaginario colectivo del binomio
carreta burro y de repente atractivos a
los veterinarios de mexicalia que
checaran estos duros porque pensaban que
estaban siendo lastimados os resultan
estos dos bien en más de 20 años cuando
el promedio nacional en méxico es de 5 a
7 años algo están siendo algo están
haciendo minutos señores
el cuento contaba las historias de mi
ciudad cosas que muchos desconocen y
esto es constante en los niños les
gustan los niños están empezamos a hacer
esculturas pero la magia la magia de
esto es que los niños con discapacidades
se enganchan los niños se acercan y lo
que estamos ahorita buscando nuestro
siguiente proyecto es construir el
primer corral altas no terapia para que
el último ciclo de vida de esos burros
estén en la ciudad si avanzamos y
teníamos que hacer esto todo esto era
y entender que lo que estábamos haciendo
tiene un impacto en las personas
realmente de los señores estaban
creyendo que tenemos la oportunidad hoy
trabajamos para que esto continúe y esto
es lo que pasa generamos visualidad
generamos esa sensación de orgullo
guarente la habitualidad es lo que
estamos hoy a través de esta metodología
provocando
es impresionante lo que pasa con una
camiseta común y que la gente se reía y
se la pongo por todos lados
ese es el hallazgo es lo que estamos
compartiendo si esta metodología que ya
terminamos se aplica a otras tradiciones
que en el mundo o en nuestra ciudad o en
el país se extinguen tenemos una
oportunidad ya encontramos el camino
señales muchas gracias